[Musik]
in der westschweiz formiert sich ende
der 70er jahre eine sekte deren
schicksal die ganze welt schockieren
wird
ihre anhänger bezeichnen sich als ort wo
die tombola sonnen templer
[Musik]
mitte der 90er jahre reist die sekte
weltweit 74 menschen in den tod
alleine der schweiz sterben 48
mitglieder auch in kanada und frankreich
kommen sollen ein blaues leben wie
konnte es soweit kommen
ich glaube der ganze voll herz nur
dimension wo minuten erforschen
[Musik]
mein bruder als sieben schüsse in den
kopf bekommen
meine schwägerin 9 mein neffe 5 und
meine schüsse waren
[Musik]
in cherry im kanton freiburg geschieht
im oktober 1994 das unfassbare auf einem
bauernhof oberhalb des dorfes bricht
feuer aus und das gebäude brennt bis auf
die grundmauern nieder
das feuer ist absichtlich gelegt worden
um die spuren in einem der
spektakulärsten kriminalfälle der
schweiz zu verwischen
am tatort findet die polizei 23 leichen
der rätselhafte fall löst ein weltweites
medienecho aus
wir können ihn heute bestätigen dass
nicht in allen fällen aber in gewissen
fällen kein selbstmord sondern tötung
vorliegt
fast 20 jahre nach dem massaker kehrt
christian brücker an den tatort zurück
im herbst 1994 stand er hier als
inspektor der kantonspolizei freiburg im
einsatz
äußerlich erinnert nichts mehr an die
grausame tat
wir befinden uns oberhalb von cherry
einem grundstück wo der bahnhof der
sekte stand im innern des hauses haben
wir die toten gefunden
ich zeige ihnen nun einige beweisstücke
die wir hier am tatort gefunden haben
es handelt sich um sehr auffällige
beweisstücke wie diesen umhang den die
meisten todesopfer toben schwerter wie
dieses dem sonnentempel symbol und
speziellen inschriften und schließlich
das kernstück für unsere untersuchung
die schusswaffe der die meisten opfer in
cherry umgebracht wurden
[Musik]
dieser mann steht am anfang der
sonnentempel sekte so di mambo
selbsternannte als verkünder und guru
[Musik]
ihm und seinen helfern gelingt es über
500 säcke jünger mit apokalyptischen
endzeit ideen zu verführen
wir sind zu faul und zu passiv wir haben
immer gewartet dass unsere meister die
propheten und christus uns die arbeit
abnehmen
nun aber sind wir der besten position um
unser eigenes positives potenzial
einzusetzen
um all unsere noblen ziele zu erreichen
seien wir ehrenhafte ritter in unserer
immerwährenden suche einer sie
traktierten sektor dass sie
ausgerichtete schufen google von prophet
also personen sondern leaderfigur und
auf der anders sieht ist ja auch
charakterisiert durch ihre lehrer die
lehrer wo meistens anzieht szenario
enthalte tvo einen wahrheitsanspruch
garten macht also das alles erklärbar
ist innerhalb von der lehr und wo auch
seine weltsicht von gut und böse also
vor müssen und ihnen dort darlegen
[Musik]
begonnen hat alles 1978 in der nähe von
genf
[Musik]
der schweizer komponist und dirigent
michelle technik befreundet sich mit dem
franzosen jo di mambo einem
vorbestraften beauty beide interessieren
sich für esoterik philosophie und
spiritualität die mambo ruft die
stiftung goldener foundation ins leben
michelle technik ist gründungsmitglied
und während vier jahren präsident
später wird daraus der ort wo die
tombola der sonnen templerorden
[Musik]
in blau resort bei genf kann die
stiftung 1978 ein herrschaftliches
anwesen erwerben die man broschardt eine
gruppe von rund 30 gleichgesinnten um
sich auch michelle tabak schnick rechts
im bild lebt in den anfangsjahren in der
kommune die mam bus unheils lehre fällt
auf fruchtbaren boden
so beginnen alle legenden
für uns wird es heute abend nicht anders
sein
ich sage euch nur es ist eine ganz alte
geschichte
durch die schöpfung für die trennung der
geschlechter zu den vorstellungen von
gut und böse von vereinigung und
trennung
doch diese antagon ihnen werden sich
aufheben symbol dieser in volution ist
der buchstabe s
[Musik]
als punkt des bewusstseins der oben und
unten verbindet als punkt des lichts vor
dem alle gegner schafften dahin fallen
michael tabat schnitt wurde später ein
wichtiger zeitzeuge welche rolle spielte
er im drama wie viel wusste er 2006 also
zwölf jahre nach dem drama spricht er in
der tagesschau des westschweizer
fernsehens
sie waren der einzige beschuldigte in
der angelegenheit sonnentempel wenn ich
sehe wer denn sonst hat diese massaker
organisiert alle verantwortlichen sind
tot das ist das drama dieser geschichte
da es keinen verantwortlichen mehr gab
musste anzünden ok und die medien haben
entschieden dass sich der dirigent
mischnick dazu bestens eignet
das sonne templer drama endete für
michel tabak nick zweimal vor dem
französischen richter diese späteren
strafverfahren von 2001 und 2006 hatten
für ihn strafrechtlich keinerlei folgen
doch zurück zu den anfängen das anwesen
der stiftung bei genf ist weitläufig in
den 80er jahren wächst die gruppe und
auch ihr besitz ein monatlicher beitrag
von mindestens 160 franken ist pflicht
schenkungen sind hochwillkommen von genf
aus rekrutieren die sonne templer neue
mitglieder in frankreich und kanada
der harte kern lebt in kommunen und
betreibt biologischen landbau die man
bloß leere umfasst rigorose essens
regeln zur mitgliederwerbung setzt die
sekte auch auf werbe- und
schulungsvideos
[Musik]
um sich vor schlechten einflüssen und
umweltgiften zu schützen
kennen die sonne templer abstrus
anmutenden tricks ein gurken ende
schneidet man ab dann reitet man es mit
dem anschnitt kreisförmig im
uhrzeigersinn bis weißer schaum entsteht
das sind die giftstoffe die austreten
die waadtländerin rosmarie karton hat im
sekten drama vier familienangehörige
verloren ihren bruder daniel ihre
schwägerin madeleine sowie ihren neffen
lionel und ihre nichte arme die
hintergründe des dramas recherchiert sie
auf eigene faust von der sekten
mitgliedschaft ihres bruders hat sie
erst nach seinem tod erfahren
wir hatten keine ahnung dass er mitglied
einer sekte
erst mit dem späteren wissen konnte ich
gewisse vorkommen ist sehr richtig
interpretieren hätte ich früher von
seiner sekten mitgliedschaft gewusst
hätte ich vielleicht rechtzeitig erkannt
dass mit der familie meines bruders
etwas nicht stimmen konnte
[Musik]
wenn sie beispielsweise meine eltern zum
tee oder zum essen besuchten setzen sie
sich nie hin
später erfuhren wir von angeblichen
strahlungen und kosmischen vibrationen
die sie daran hinderten da platz zu
nehmen wo zuvor jemand anderes seinen
allerwertesten hingesetzt hatte ziemlich
erstaunlich von dem mambo hieß es dass
er auf seinen flugreisen eine isolations
platte aus metall mit führte um nicht
negativen strahlen ausgesetzt zu sein
seit 1975 beschäftigt sich hugo stamm
als journalist und buchautor mit sekten
bei den sonnen templern ortet er das
klassische grundmuster die duchess gibt
spirituelle welt und das ist die
wirkliche welt und die weltliche aspekt
die sind eigentlich sekundär und das
dort darum das eigene spirituelle
potenzial zu entwickeln
das heißt quasi erleuchtet werde sich
befreien vor allem irdischen bedingtheit
als spirituelles werden und letztlich
denn sich so weiterentwickeln dass mehr
frequenzen energie frequenz wie die
göttliche kraft
und wenn wir haben quasi teil von
göttlichen system zum ersten mal zeigt
die freiburger kantonspolizei insekten
video mit jo di mambo dass in den
brandruinen gefunden wurde
wir haben vor ort in cheri eine
beachtliche anzahl vhs-kassetten
gefunden die es videomaterial half und
zu verstehen wie die sonnentempel intern
funktionierten die aufnahmen ermöglichen
uns zudem aufschlüsse über die symbolik
und das abdriften der sekte zu erhalten
dominik entferne die rose und bringt das
kind bitte nach vorne
[Musik]
von gott gesegnetes und vom heiligen
geist empfangen das mädchen der team am
boden ist erich spirituelle fantasiert
ritual entwickelt und harris besonders
raffinierten attacke
die entwickler
[Musik]
das abo cooper tochter saab zu beginn
hat mir die sekte sehr viel gebracht
es gab immer aktivitäten yogakurse moral
gesamt beispielsweise es kann man auch
interessante leute von überall her zu
uns
[Musik]
es gibt die unterschiedlichsten seminare
wir hatten ein ausgefülltes
abwechslungsreiches leben
ich glaube deshalb merkt man nicht wie
man ganz langsam immer mehr
indoktriniert wird man ist völlig
eingelöst
man vergisst die welt um sich herum die
familie so sehr wird man vereinnahmt
dass man nicht einmal mehr merkt es gibt
eine free zone templer haben viele
merkmal von 6 1 auf gewesen
sehr zu machen man sagen kontrollen über
mitglieder die hand müsse geld ab so wie
das gegangen ist oder sie haben müssen
fronarbeit leiste als zweit wichtigste
merkmal ist kein halt ich sie bewusst
weder nachbarn hand das erfahren was die
da machen
so hat man das besagte spezialisten
kvist was da los ist wo dann die masse
tätigen und masse passiert sind sind
alle überrascht und kann gar nicht
können erklären was ist das für 6
den auserwählten stellt die mambo den
transit auf den stern sirius in aussicht
verbunden mit der wiedergeburt dieses
gedankengut holte er sich bei den alten
ägyptern das erscheinen von sirius
kündigte den ägyptern die nil flut an
sirius galt als sicherer vorbote für
eine reiche ernte deshalb verehrten sie
diesen stern besonders mehrmals reist
eine gruppe der sonne templer unter der
führung von julie mambo nach ägypten
[Musik]
auch der schweizer komponist michel
tabat schnick ist bei den sogenannten
bildungsreisen an den nil mit dabei
[Musik]
in dieser zeit erscheint seiner
komposition cosmo coni für eine rose es
ist wohl kaum ein zufall dass auf tabak
schnick endzeit stimmung aufkommen lässt
in seinem werk vertont er den übertritt
in andere dimensionen und die endgültige
auflösung des universums
[Musik]
inhalte die auch im mittelpunkt von joe
die mambas weltsicht stehen er schwört
seine anhänger früh auf die endzeit ein
und bedient sich erneut bei den alten
ägyptern ist die wiederauferstehung von
osiris nicht unsere eigene
wiederauferstehung ist die rückkehr von
isis nicht unsere eigene rückkehr
möchtet ihr euch
in dieser rückkehr zum anfang erkennen
der genfer tribune kennt die
verführungskraft die man bruce er war
jahrelang mitglied der sekte die rituale
auf dem anwesen in der nähe von genf hat
er selbst mitgemacht früh morgens um 5
uhr versammelten sich die
sektenmitglieder unter diesem baum
die mango sagte uns dieser baum sei der
beschützer der stiftung am tag an dem
ein blitzen und baum einschlage oder
eher um falle werde die stunde der
großen rückkehr sein
[Musik]
das ende der welt noch ist es nicht
soweit
zusammen mit michelle tabat schnitt von
judy munro gewinnt ein dritter mann an
einfluss der belgische homöopath luxury
ein mann des wortes der den fortgang des
sonnen templer dramas entscheidend
mitbestimmt wird
er wird neue mitglieder an hält vorträge
und kommt vor allem bei den weiblichen
teilnehmern gut an
[Musik]
kindler der wichtigste moment für den
menschen ist die pflege der gemeinsamen
mahlzeit an einem tisch und überall auf
der welt bedeutet diese freundschaften
zu knüpfen und zu pflegen
niemand hätte luxuria also sind sie
quasi workshop beteilige die
öffentlichkeit duftreis erste
ausseminister sie und das ist schon sehr
speziell sind das dritte trophy dass der
schotte mambo bang generalstabsmäßige
plant trainer will frage dass also der
masse zieht möglicherweise im cockpit
wird vom landkreis im dezember 1992 nach
dem tod unseres vaters war die gesamte
familie versammelt mein bruder sagte mir
damals ich werde mich umbringen lassen
zehn tage vor dem wasser kann in der
schweiz ruft die sekte ihre mitglieder
zu einer wichtigen konferenz ins novotel
nach avignon hauptthema die zukünftige
mission des ordens einer der drei
hauptredner
mt michelle technik nach dem drama
spricht er im schweizer fernsehen über
diese zusammenkunft
[Musik]
ich wurde von hermann hambro und herrn
verlage eingeladen
das treffen kam ganz informell zustande
obama telefonierte mir und bat mich
einen vortrag zu halten und das habe ich
sehr gerne gemacht
knapp zwei jahre nach dem drama
realisierte der filmemacher eric
bergkraut für das schweizer fernsehen
einen dokumentarfilm über die sonnen
templer
er sprach mit michelle technik und
recherchierte im umfeld der sekte es hat
eigentlich direkt mit der angehörigen
der sechs retter zum ärger der mauer ich
zumindest man muss da sehr präzise der
mache ich zum hinterstoder waren habe
ich vor viele mitglieder schlüsselfigur
als sehr sauber stellt sampras
manipulierter da von jo timo boll
manipulierte verführte berg hat fragte
beck im exklusiv-interview ob er seine
freundschaft zu dem mann drohen nach dem
drama noch verteidigen
das ist keine aggressive frage sondern
eine frage die mir sehr weh tut
die mam rat menschen in den tod
getrieben die ich geliebt habe ich habe
diese man vertrauter sein ich bat
präsident der golden bay fondation zu
werden
alles habe ich ihm gegeben mich selbst
habe ich ihm gegeben
er hat mich verführt die mambo hatte
demzufolge eine große macht wieder sie
verfügung
das bestimmt sagten dass ich will ganz
leicht zu verstauen dass die brillante
künstler gebildeter mann der branche
eigentlich in abhängigkeit sich vor dem
serbien
für mich völlig ich segne dich mit rose
und kreuz so die man brot auf das
angeblich kosmische kind der
sonnentempel in wirklichkeit entstand er
manuell chris unter sehr irdischen
umständen so di mambo ist der vater er
schwängerte ein sektenmitglied
[Musik]
dieses kind wurde weder durch zufall
noch menschliches zutun geboren es
entstand durch den geist und den wunsch
der meister wir nennen es immer mehr als
ausdruck der körperlichen offenbarung
des göttlichen gesetzes sein kosmischer
names chris weil es christus in sich
trägt
das mädchen muss völlig abgeschirmt von
der außenwelt aufwachsen
innerhalb der sekte kommt immer nur
chris eine gottähnliche rolle zu
[Musik]
das schweizerisch kanadische ehepaar
niki und toni die tor will sich 1994 von
der sekte lösen
die mambo ist ungehalten sie reizen ihn
zusätzlich indem sie ihren neugeborenen
sohn christopher emanuel nennen der
gleiche name den jo di mambo für sand
kosmisches kind in anspruch nimmt
diese provokation ist wohl der auslöser
für das ganze kommende unheil die mambo
erklärt das baby christopher emanuel zum
antichristen und schickt
sektenmitglieder nach kanada um zu
morgen mit dabei der freiburger joel
egger am 30 september 1994 schlagen die
sonnen templer in der provinz quebec ins
städtchen maureen heitz zu
[Musik]
fünf personen sterben die junge familie
die zwar mit christopher emanuel zwei
der keller richten sich nach den
auftragsmorden selbst
eine leiche wurde in der nähe der beiden
erster opfer gefunden
ein kleiner und weniger als ein jahr alt
sein körper war hinter einem boiler
versteckt ein brand soll spuren
verwischen
[Musik]
kanada ist erst der auftakt zum sekten
drama
nach ihrer rückkehr in die schweiz
beordert die mambo schlecker und weitere
sonnentempel nach cherry im kanton
freiburg
[Musik]
nun macht er ernst mit dem transit auf
den stern serie
[Musik]
hat den mut über euch hinauszugehen
seit bei der goldenen dämmerung dabei
nicht als zuschauer sondern als
mitwirkende als mitwirkende
wir werden diese gruppe sein wir müssen
in den kommenden stunden und tagen allen
profanen und materiellen ballast auf der
welt zurück lassen bevor wir sie
verlassen können um meine schilliger
harmonie
mit dem großen architekten werden zu
können
gebt euch die hände
[Musik]
die mambo setzt jetzt seinen tödlichen
plan um in dieser oktobernacht von 1994
passiert etwas unfassbares wie in kanada
soll auch in der schweiz ein brand die
spuren verwischen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in cherry sterben 23 sonnentempel
der freiburger untersuchungsrichter und
replay wird mit der ermittlung
beauftragt in der brandnacht fährt er
sofort nach cherry noch heute erinnert
er sich genau an die gespenstische
szenerie verschiedene autos cool damit
verschiedene
immatrikulation schildern sogar und
regulation steuerverfahren krieg und
damir dankt wo sind das ist die frage
ist wo sind sie lügt und dann
konzentriert auf der unterbau für die
schüler nach langem suchen und zwar in
der versteckte tür in der wand in zimmer
dann offen china gestoßen
und da im tasche land regiert haben wir
dann effektive stellt das sequel dass
ich dann nach alex und wo mir dann
gebietet die hauptwege die nato sind sie
mir folgendes gestanden und sind im
kreis bei 15 bis 20 personen klagen
sämtliche personen
bloß die sehr viele mit plastiksack über
dem kopf
die uniqa ein halber tag sie dass sie
schusswunden im kopf gehängt
da haben wir dann langsam sie feststellt
dass man vor so große problem sind
zu diesem zeitpunkt war noch nicht klar
ob es sich um einen massen suizid oder
eine massentötung handelte
[Musik]
angesicht dieses dramas habe ich mich
entschlossen heute abend im fernsehen zu
sprechen nur weil er trainiere ich bin
sehr aufgewühlt
nie hätte ich es für möglich gehalten
dass ein so positive aufbruch so enden
könnte positiv sie will das brot man
glaubt besser zu sein als alle anderen
man will es so sehr dass man egoistisch
wird so egoistisch dass man fähig ist
sich selbst zu töten
gerichtsmediziner thomas compare hat in
seinem beruf schon vieles erlebt aber
noch nie ein solches massaker in meiner
karriere habe ich verschenke
katastrophen aus der nähe erlebt locker
wie und madrid beispielsweise eigentlich
war ich also vorbereitet doch dieser
fall übertrifft alle anderen das
abscheulichste was ich je gesehen habe
wir waren schockiert haben geweint
am liebsten hätte man heraus geschrieben
warum
als wir den obduktion vorliegen hat uns
professor compassion der die autopsie
geleitet hat versichert im falle unsere
familie seien alle vier mitglieder
ermordet wurden selbstmord schloss er
aus das war der auslöser für rosmarie
kartons eigene nachforschungen das haus
ihrer vier verstorbenen
familienmitglieder befand sich nach dem
massaker in ordentlichem zustand
man hat den eindruck sie müssen das haus
in aller eile verlassen
das ist das thema meiner nichte arme als
wir das drinnen wegzogen entdeckten wir
einen blutfleck wir vermuten dass sie
bereits zu hause unter drogen gesetzt
worden ist
der autopsie bericht erwähnt einen
nadeleinstiche an ihrem arm vermutlich
hat dieser nadeleinstiche dazu geführt
dieses blatt haben die auf e mails
bürotisch geführt
sie hat offensichtlich versucht noch
eine botschaft zu hinterlassen
doch unter drogeneinfluss hat sie nur
dieses gekitzelt
gebracht zb leider ist es völlig unnötig
was geschah genau ermittlungen ergaben
die meisten sektenmitglieder wurden beim
eintreffen in cherry mit einem
giftcocktail betäubt und anschließend
mit dieser waffe hingerichtet
kurz darauf waren vermutlich zwei
personenwagen richtung bands
in einem auto sitzen vier insassen
höchstwahrscheinlich gehören jo di mambo
und der freiburger jagger dazu
[Musik]
ziel der fahrt ist das walliser dorf
salon wo sektenmitglieder drei chalets
besitzen auch dorthin hat die mambo
seine betreuer bestellt darunter das
ehemalige sektenmitglied zu erinnern
ich war am nachmittag hochgefahren und
die mambo ein letztes mal zu treffen
als er die tür öffnete bekam ich es mit
der angst zu tun
da war dieser vinzi gestank der mir in
die nase stark ich fragte mich was das
zu bedeuten hat und ich begriff
überhaupt nichts mehr
irgendetwas in mir drin sagte mehr bloß
weg hier
ich verabschiedete mich schroff brannte
zu meinem auto zurück die man groß
freundin holte mich ein
sie hat versucht mich zurückzuhalten
gelingt die flucht wenig später brennt
es auch in salon diesmal gm drive alles
in flammen auf
[Musik]
wie sein freiburger kollege macht sich
auch robert steiner chef der
kriminalpolizei in der brandnacht auf
nach salon
jetzt sind auch mal große rätsel
gestanden wie lange das der das gange
ist die der elfter stunde modell wir
feststellen dass viele tote sind
insbesondere in eine schale hat annika
im anderen 5 c a sowie in der
innenschale die liga sehr eingebrannt
und verbrannt sind sie wenn man das so
darf sagen bis zur unkenntlichkeit oder
bist du dich noch erreichte und im
anderen schale sind etliche meter
weniger nicht in taxi aber am ende
weniger nur besser erhalten als als
solche
robert steiner begibt sich zu einem der
drei brandorte oberhalb von salva das
chalet ist bis auf die grundmauern
abgebrannt
einzig ein ofen und ein nebengebäude
stehen heute noch im wallis mussten
insgesamt 25 sec mitglieder sterben
vorerst war unklar was mit den
sektenguru die mambo und luxury
geschehen war hatten sie womöglich
überlebt 100 prozentige sicherheit dass
der sohn die mutter litt schule da sind
umso warum bin ich so sicher wie wir
damals die gerichtsmediziner hexe zu
eine neue methode kraft zusätzlich zu
den finger trägt zusätzlich zum oder
unter gramm das heißt also zum thema
doch damals fanden ist jetzt 100
prozentige sicherheit gestürzt
experten auf die arbeit war man macht
das die zwei sind im prinzip hier vor
ort gestorben
die schweizer untersuchungsbehörden
kamen zu folgendem schluss die mambo
ließ die mehrheit der sektenmitglieder
umbringen das vergiften und erschießen
haben seine getreuen luxury & joy lecker
ausgeführt danach vergiftete sich das
trio selbst
so di mambo hatte geldsorgen und war
krank
seine wahren motive bleiben letztlich
ein rätsel
michelle tabarz schneck war bei den
massentötungen nicht dabei als mann mit
großem einfluss in der sekte geräte aber
ins fadenkreuz der untersuchung und der
medien die tagesschau des westschweizer
fernsehens konfrontiert ihn 1996 mit
seiner sonnen templer vergangenheit die
regie zeitungsfotos der industrie darauf
sind sie zu sehen
man hat nicht den eindruck dass sie eine
rede halten es sieht vielmehr danach aus
als würden sie ein ritual leiten
glauben sie nicht dass all diese
unklarheiten dazu beitragen dass sie
zwar kein krimineller sind aber dass man
dennoch den eindruck bekommt sie würden
nicht die ganze wahrheit sagen sie haben
sich richter mit
und warum ist es so weil ich selbst mit
die mama probleme hatte auch ich sah
dinge die mich störten hat einen
schwierigen autoritären charakter
einerseits wollte ich nichts mehr mit
ihm zu tun haben weil ich mit seinen
ideen nicht einverstanden war
andererseits waren wir seit 15 jahren
befreundet hingegen habe ich nie ein
dilemma bezüglich meiner sonnentempel
vorträge weil die leute zu dem ich
sprach keine verbindung mit di mambo
hatten
was meine persönliche beziehung zu die
mambo betrifft so hatte ich enorme
probleme mit ihm
aber all das ist schwierig in zwei drei
sätzen vor publikum zu erklären
bild obs er wisse dass die katze gewusst
und formuliert das als ein ziel von der
sekte wird
ein bereits auf sirius sie ein übergang
in sandersleben otto wie wird das er
über idee ziemlich kurzfristig
organisiert die übergangs das hat mir
die kinder feststellen
mangels beweisen wird der blick in der
schweiz nicht angeklagt
14 monate nach chili und salz kommt es
etwa 200 kilometer von der schweizer
grenze entfernt in einer waldlichtung in
frankreich erneut zu einem massenmord
diesmal bezahlen 16 menschen ihre
zugehörigkeit zum sonnen templerorden
mit dem leben das morden geht auch nach
jobs tod weiter bis heute ist ungeklärt
wer diesen transit angeordnet und
durchgeführt hat
wieder im fadenkreuz der ermittler wie
schild im gegensatz zur schweiz klagt
frankreich ihn an das geistige terra für
die morde vorbereitet zu haben
die prozesse in den jahren 2001 und 2006
in grenoble verfolgt rosmarie atom vor
ort musste sein leben von anfang an
erzählt nichts neues immer noch leben
na gut ich für meinen teil habe den
ganzen prozess also sämtliche fragen und
antworten zum ersten bis zum letzten
verhandlungstag mit stenografie sowohl
2001 wie auch beim berufungsprozess 2006
wird michel kacnik freigesprochen sich
wissentlich an der organisation der
morde beteiligt zu haben
darauf verschärfte frankreich seien
sekten gesetz in der schweiz passierte
nichts in der schweiz haben eine andere
grundhaltung gegenüber sektor schweiz
ist er ähnlich wie in amerika man hat
grundhaltung dass auch jene gruppierung
soll es existiere das wenn man das
verhältnis zu gott und zum überirdische
halt immer so nach lienen gemeinschaft
suchen dass das durchaus legitim ist
sogar vor der religions- und
glaubensfreiheit abdeckt und dass man
erst trifft wenn ganz klar erkannt war
staatsfeindliche oder individuell
schädigen die fahrten swiss am tag trat
trotz der beiden freisprüche in
frankreich sind bei rosmarie karton
zweifel an michelle tabat schnix rolle
geblieben
seit 1994 hat sie dutzende von berichten
und interviews zum fall gesammelt und
analysiert
je länger ich mich damit beschäftige
desto überzeugt hat bin ich halt
abschnitt hat von interview zu interview
immer ein kleines bisschen weniger
gewesen
es ist zu spät ihn ins gefängnis zu
bringen aber wenn er wenigstens einmal
die wahrheit
dann könnte er hatte eine hohe
moralische verantwortung denn er hat
eine lehre mit verbreitete von den
sektenmitgliedern geglaubt wurde
sie waren diesen kurs völlig
ausgeliefert seine rituale pixi und nur
schrott oder umstand dass dji mambo ihn
verehrt hat und nicht so eine rolle
gespielt weil bedeutung zugemessen
mitglieder eine autoritäts figur xiii
sie einen urlaub der hat er immer
sonderstellung der sekte und darum hat
er zumindestens mental die
indoktrination gefördert erich
aushängeschild sie ertrag bayerischen
gestanden hat das verkraftbar
und das hat natürlich mitglieder auf
klar das ist eine verstärkung von den
industrienationen kommt schon die mambo
es reicht also menschen die moralische
schuld trifft und für mehr hexe
innerhofer maß
schuldig sind sicher der sektenführer
und die leute im inneren kern wo das mit
3.000 wo es strafrechtlicher sicht jetzt
eigentlich somit plant hand und mittäter
sind von ganze aber auch daran dass sie
dann muss man da gesehen also strafrecht
bedeutet dass man das muss keine
bewiesen dass da kein zweifel
damit wirklich existiert und das ist
natürlich unheimlich schwer so biss
bewiesen das zeige da die beiden
strafverfahren in frankreich gebaut
schnick wo dann mit freisprüchen geendet
hat also das heißt es gibt hohe hürde um
selbst strafrechtlich zu verfolgen aber
sicher sind wie lüd im engeren zirkel
die elite vor der sekte sind moralisch
mitverantwortlich für das was passiert
ist
[Musik]
heute ist michelle tabat schnitt wieder
ein gefragter dirigent auf dem
internationalen parkett
sf dok hat ihn zur mitwirkung in diesem
film eingeladen
über seinen sekretär lässt er ausrichten
mischnick hat das kapitel sonnentempel
abgeschlossen er wünscht sich dazu in
keiner weise mehr zu äußern
auf ihrem höhepunkt zählte die sonne
templer sekte vor allem in der schweiz
frankreich und kanada über 500
mitglieder
was ist aus den überlebenden geworden
existiert die sekte vielleicht noch es
gibt immer wieder gerüchte szene wo seit
das könnte nur einzelne splittergruppe
gehe aber mehrere nicht bekannt und ich
halte es auch nicht für sehr
wahrscheinlich will
inzwischen zieht weiß mehr dass die
vision vom turm empor fantasiegebilde
sie sind also der apokalyptische endzeit
stürmische tage hinweg sagt
74 menschen hat der vermeintliche
transit auf den stern sirius und die
erhoffte wiedergeburt in den tod
gerissen
[Musik]
der baum den judy man brot zum verkünder
des weltuntergangs hochstilisierte steht
auch heute noch auf der wiese in der
nähe von genf dort wo das sonnen templer
drama seinen anfang genommen hat
[Musik]